J'ai décidé de tenir un journal pour
consigner toutes mes pensées et une simple
offense de ma journée
je garderai ce journal pendant un an et
au bout de ce temps il sera
détruit
j'encourage mon fils à s'enrôler c'était une
famille  tradition six mois plus tard il était
mort en Irak j'étais perdu les cours la
lecture du Seigneur louange a commencé
[Musique]
alors qui es tu je vais bien non vraiment ça
fait un moment qu'on n'a pas parlé même un
pasteur a besoin de bâtard tu as vu  le
docteur tu as besoin de quelqu'un pour s'occuper de
toi mais je veux que tu sois heureuse je sais
que rien ne peut changer et je sais qu'il
n'y a aucun espoir oui madame les explosifs elle
devenait quelqu'un que je ne connaissais pas
les maladies opportunistes et notre clé
martiale  loi tu vivras pour voir ça
tu n'avais aucune idée de ce qu'il pensait non
j'ai tellement peur ces enfants ils veulent la
certitude tu sais ne pense pas suivre
ils sont la proie de l'extrémisme c'est un monde
sans maison non je n'ai pas perdu la face
toi  Je pense que ce que nous avons fait ensemble était un
synthé, j'ai vu assez de vrais péchés  pour savoir
la différence que vous ne l'avez pas dit s'il vous plaît
jetez un œil à votre propre vie avant de
critiquer les autres
ce sont des temps effrayants nous devons
être patients bien quelqu'un doit faire
quelque chose
dans le dieu qui purifie l'âme
je
[Musique]
mes mains tremblent  alors que j'écris ces lignes
et que Dieu nous pardonne pour ce que nous avons fait
à ce monde qui pourrait connaître la pensée de
Dieu
vous